how's it going guys
matt from codetechnatorials i was just
thinking today and kind of had somewhat
of a
revelation now i've got this weird mic
that i'm just holding
this is god
what am i doing with my life all right
so forget the mic
just you gotta be able to hear me right
so i was thinking about a person today
that
at some point i decided i didn't really
like
all right so this is sort of related to
cancer cancer culture and i realized
that
uh i'm an idiot basically
not for not liking them that's just kind
of how i naturally felt
but i had like all this weird stigmatism
in my mind about them
and like like i knew their thoughts
already and that sort of thing
and i realized that
i've learned a lot from this person more
than i learned from most people
more than i learned from most people i
like and that's
that's kind of a big deal my whole
life's really all about
learning and improving and getting
better
and it's it's really interesting because
i've spent 15
i don't know 10 15 years of my life like
not really caring
uh things were like pretty good around
me
and i wasn't doing anything other than
being myself and not even thinking about
it
and then like one day i was like uh i
gotta i gotta get to the next level i
gotta
self-improve i gotta finish my degree
i gotta work on my hobbies every day
that are actually beneficial
i can't just goof off every day and
you know go to work come home goof off
go to work
next day same thing over and over i
wasn't really like
scaling up anything it was all like
i don't know maybe there's more to it
than i realize now because
in a lot of ways i gained
a lot of uh you know just new
like social skills and things like that
just by interacting with a lot of
different people
especially at work especially in games
and friends and
stuff like that so this person
the story is about it's not really about
them it's more about the realization
but i'll give a little background so
it's not so
hidden and dark i guess or you know
so you can understand the pictures what
i'm trying to say not dark
isn't like yeah dark isn't like you
can't see
the picture the picture is basically
this i have a
long time friend from like way back in
grade school days even i think we maybe
even knew each other but we weren't
really friends to like high school sort
of thing
but it's been a long time we're all
grown up we got kids we got
you know normal life i guess and
yeah his wife had a mutual friend that
was this
girl and she was
i don't know i was just over at their
house hanging out and she
like was there too
and uh it wasn't it was
it didn't get off on a good foot for her
we'll say like
it was it was a really hard for me to
like her
and it wasn't anything bad she was just
like
overly touchy feely and it's not really
something i was into especially right
when we're
aware of uh you know what breaking out
in the world i was like okay
i don't know you very well but also like
the first thing she said to me was like
hey do you remember me and i didn't
but apparently i met her before like 10
years ago but
like i didn't know that so i was just
like oh no this is awkward
uh maybe maybe i've heard we met
it was one of those things but i didn't
want to like make it
rude so i tried not to it's like hey
so i don't know it was weird
you know it's it's interesting how when
you first meet someone even if you don't
particularly like them
you feel like you're obligated to be
nice to them
and that's kind of how i felt and i
could kind of tell after a while that
she was just
spaced out she was in her own world
and i i don't know how to
i guess i'll just explain it she was
like
she kind of felt like she was the
all-seeing all-knowing of
how the world should be how to
you know how to party how to i don't
know she basically just partied a lot
she didn't really have any real hobbies
other than partying so that's
extremely unattractive to me that just
makes me want to say
get away from me kind of after a while
it's like so anyway that's
and that's not me trying to be
rude because i'm kind of part of your
too or at least i was at some point
but if that's all you do that's that's a
really useless hobby
so i guess i recognized that pretty
early on
but you know that that's all it would be
you know
any time hanging out with her is you're
like either drinking or smoking or both
and i might be okay every once in a
while but that's not really something
that
is gonna help me with my my goals
so she was really weird she was like
i think she thought i was stupid like
that's the only thing i can really
assume like at this point
which you know is backwards because
i don't consider myself particularly
intelligent but
i've kind of noticed over the years that
i'm obviously more intelligent than most
people
and it's weird because i
apparently when you're intelligent you
don't feel intelligent so maybe it's
something like that that whole effect
like you realize that you don't know
much
and you know the people that don't know
much don't realize that they don't know
much that sort of thing
i sort of sort of like that so she
seemed like she really didn't
actually didn't know much she you know
she could get a job and
live her life and pay her bills or
whatever that was fine
but it wasn't like ever anything more
than that other than just partying in
the evening
so
i don't know yeah i'll just tell the
story so we got drunk
all of us yeah we got a little junk we
were playing some cards
and at one point my drunk friend was
like oh man you got to stay away from
her she's crazy
and i had already kind of noticed she
was crazy and i was like thanks for the
warning buddy
that's why you and i are friends
you tell me how it is you know that sort
of thing um
so obviously i took his heed to his
warning but
he wouldn't have done that if he wasn't
really drunk he was just like honest
drunk it was kind of that
thing and uh
you know eventually
i kind of realized that
i don't know i i couldn't i didn't want
to just be mean for no reason you know
so i was nice to her but after a while
it got really really really annoying
like her humor was very different than
my humor and like
when she would send me stuff or say
stuff
i would like have no option but to stare
at her dumbfoundly like
you would actually say and send stupid
stuff like that
like and i think that made her think
that i didn't get it or something but
it's like it's not that i don't get it
it's just terrible humor and
i i didn't know that anybody thought
this was funny you know i guess it's
like a lot of my reaction videos
basically
except for the ones where i'm laughing
at programming humor
i know it was stuff like you know click
bait into
showing you like really really crude
humor and it was like for me i guess the
whole problem was it's like
man i i'm
you know i have to accept that um
i'm around people decent people and i'm
around
kids and stuff so i can't just be
opening stuff on my phone that's like
click bait into screaming obscenities
and
click bait into uh nudity and stuff like
that
and that's that's like that was her
humor she would just send me stuff like
that so i was just like what are you
doing so i sent her a few warnings i was
like why are you sending me stuff like
this and i was like
okay can you not send me that and then
like happened a few more times i was
like
holy you know what do you do at that
point so i was just like
all right you know i've said a few
things uh block button
so there it was and
i don't know like what what he'll what
else do you do at that point
if someone that you're supposed to be
friends with in real life is like
spamming you with stuff that's totally
awful and inappropriate and you've told
them you don't want to do it do you just
block them do you just cut them out of
your life
so yeah i really didn't like her at all
was not a fan
she had maybe a one percent fandom for
me going on so that was it was like 99
of me i absolutely did not really like
her at all it was pretty it was pretty
bad after a little while like after i
got to know how
she thought and operated you know her
lifestyle
wow holy crap so
but then i realized later after i had
joined the cancel culture and hit the
block button on her
i learned a lot from her more than i
learned from most nice people
i had to think about how i should handle
absurd and obscene people
and i'm still thinking about it but i
don't normally think about that
usually it's pretty obvious like on
you know on online stuff when it's
not even someone you know just some
random on the internet it just doesn't
matter you can hit block you can hit
report you can say whatever you want you
can yell at them back
you know it just doesn't matter it's
just like not that much anyway you know
shouting yelling back but you
it's you're pretty open to just block
whoever you want on any social media
platform
you especially if you don't know them
but when it's someone you know and
apparently
been acquainted with for over 10 years
and didn't know it but
you're not acquainted but you know knew
them for that long and they're friends
of friends and
and things like that like what do you do
then
how do you handle that and this is
actually really important
and i've seen people lose their
livelihood because they can't
deal or cope with stuff like this
i feel like it could happen to me if i
if i don't learn this lesson
so you might think what is the lesson
the lesson is to think about it
the lesson is to not get mad and and
brash
you know that's that's the lesson the
lesson is to stay calm
and be yourself consider your options
don't needlessly make people mad that
you have no business trying to make mad
like
it's like poking the bear you're just
asking to get eaten and that's how
that's how it is on on here too
and uh you know i see from a lot of my
past videos that i'm like pretty guilty
of this
i've ragged on people a bit and i
noticed sometimes when i post these sort
of videos
i'll drop a subscriber but then it
usually goes right back up because i
think my audience is like sorting itself
out
some people think i'm strictly tutorials
or something and other people realize
that i'm actually a person
like oh can't deal with the face of a
person and i don't know it's weird a lot
of people are like that it's really
it always it always blows my mind that
people are like
you know but then there's the opposite
they're like oh i want a real person
behind it
so i don't know i i feel like that's not
really for me to decide
that's for people to decide and i've
also noticed
people are terrified of me i i guess i'm
just a scary person and i didn't realize
this
until like five years ago when i had a
girlfriend
and you know we were
engaged and stuff and had a kid and
things were going pretty well
except uh i wanted to go back to school
rather than committing to
a relationship at the time so i was just
like focused on on that
focus on learning basically programming
computer science
and so we ended up splitting up
but in one of our like you know little
arguments or whatever
uh near the end she said something that
i also
realized this is a completely different
person not the one i was talking about
earlier
i'm just talking about me being scary
now
she said you're scary when you're mad
you're terrifying when you're mad and i
can see that
and i think that's fine
i should be scary when i'm mad everyone
should be like who's afraid of someone
that's not scary when they're mad right
who's ever going to listen to them who's
ever going to care about them if they're
not even
they can't even make an effect when
they're trying to
it's odd to say but i think there's more
to it than that
i think somewhere along the way i
lost my heart it's it's gone
no it's not completely gone but at some
point i realized i was capable of
like actually you know actually hurting
people
not like physically i guess physically
too
i mean i'm somewhat trained in martial
arts so i'm not
particularly scared of anyone because i
feel like
i could uh i could figure a way
most of the time i mean sure i could
still be overpowered if someone's just
flat out
huge or something of course but in
general i grew up
wrestling stuff a lot in karate and all
that
so i'm not particularly
scared of that sort of stuff but i don't
like it i would prefer to
never have to do anything like that it's
just like if someone attacked my family
i would have some instinct as to what to
do
you know or something like that or how
to handle it but i would rather handle
everything verbally verbally seems a lot
a lot better i've been able to verbally
handle almost
every situation i've been in i've i
think i've only been in a few
very few like physical fights in my
whole life and they were chosen by me i
was the one deciding to fight
i don't know if i should talk about
those much but i guess i could talk
about it a little bit since i've gone
there
because these were other people i didn't
like that i learned a lot from
the personal story or rather not
basically there is one time a long long
time ago
over 10 years 13 years about 13 years
ago 14 years ago
somewhere around there maybe even 15.
it's been a while
i was kind of put into a fight or flight
situation
with another person who was very
so he was strange he was a bit mentally
deranged i didn't know this at first but
became apparent after a while
and i was kind of putting up yeah just a
fight or flight situation
and i really had nowhere to run so i
chose fight and i was like all right
we're doing this and we fought
we both fought pretty hard
but it was it was there was something
funny about it that was interesting that
we were like
all right let's you know no no hitting
in the face no making like
you know obvious uh underhanded moves
but
it was definitely a test of power but
there was definitely this
agreement between us where you know
we're not going to like snap
each other's arms and stuff like that
it's just like
one of us is going to submit that was it
was that sort of thing and i'm sure
people that do
jujitsu and stuff understand that
i should probably get into jujitsu i i
never have but it seems pretty
interesting
well i really didn't like that person
either and you could probably
sort of imagine why without hearing any
more of the story but i also learned a
lot from this person
actually you know i was uh i was into it
and tech at a young age
but things weren't that advanced you
know we're talking
windows 2000 windows xp was coming out
so
those weren't the most stable of os's
and weren't very good for
handling devices and drivers and stuff
it was sort of a pain
but he sort of taught me the ropes of
how a lot of the logic works for
all the stuff basically and that sort of
accelerated
my career actually a decent amount so
i learned a lot from this guy and i
don't like him either i would not talk
to him anymore
i don't care what he has to say you know
but it's
it's not what you think it's probably
worse than you think
um where i draw the line and i think
where the point to draw the line with
the whole
cancelling someone is when they're
actually dangerous
if you feel like they could cause
real harm to someone especially someone
you care about
which you know could be a lot of people
if you care about a lot of people
that's when it's time to do something
other than just say something
that's when you have to take action but
i think you should say something often
like you should try to speak your mind
often not correct you know
it's another thing that's really weird
in our culture people people want to
correct and dominate
it's like uh use the wrong they or
else man i'm you know
more than that but kind of you know they
want to tell you how to live your day
things like that but
it gets weird in some situations but one
of the things about being independent
and
and being um
you know just going into a mode where
you're all about self-improvement is you
realize you're responsible
for yourself it doesn't matter what
other people say it doesn't matter what
they tell you to do
at the end of the day your actions are
your own fault so
that means some pretty important things
like
you shouldn't listen to people because
you get to make the decision not them
you should that doesn't mean you
shouldn't
take their opinion or advice into
account
but you definitely should not be blindly
listening to
anything anyone tells you and i mean
that ever
and that really puts a hamper on things
like advertisements
advertisements will blast you all day
with ridiculously useless nonsense if
you let them
and it's really ridiculous
and people can do that to you too and
it might that works for them they want
you to drink the kool-aid they want you
to
buy the thing but should you that's the
decision you get to make
well hope you guys enjoyed this talk
i don't know if i'm going to release
this but if you're hearing this now
apparently i decided to
take care of yourselves leave me some
comments below don't forget to hit the
like button for
helping me out for helping this channel
basically to help this channel
i should say let me know your stories
you got any
crazy stories about people you learned a
lot from that you really didn't like
i'm sure people have them if they think
of them
we really got to think twice about doing
this cancel culture thing